la technologie au service de la liberté
en chine
c'est l'idée de l'opération originale
lancée aujourd'hui par un certain nombre
de magazines internationaux à commencer
par actuelle en france pour lutter
contre le silence et la propagande qui
écrase de plomb l'opinion chinoise
depuis l'été dernier
utiliser le fax vous savez cet appareil
de télécopie qui permet d'envoyer des
papiers par téléphone pour l orange est
petit et claude sicard nous en dise plus
oui oui mon vieux on va les virer le
vieux dingue
li peng aussi on les vire à tous un peu
plus durs et les chinois parlent tous
chinois
mieux encore il les informe le journal
actuel a mis à la disposition des
opposants au régime de dengue si au ping
un véritable arsenal technologique
il s'agit de transmettre jusqu'en chine
et par télécopie par fax toutes les
informations relatives à la situation
politique telle qu'on la cash flow
chinois les chinois ont besoin
d'information quel que soit aux quelques
qu'un fils que soit cette information
ils seront utilisés puisque ils ont
l'habitude de recopier de photocopier et
de diffuser ce genre de papier en
repartir il existe en chine 6000
télécopieur capable de recevoir les fax
expédié aujourd'hui ils sont le plus
souvent propriété de l'administration
communiste de deng xiaoping
c'est dire si les chances d'informer le
peuple chinois tout entier sont des plus
réduites
on passe où on peut passer la liberté
place par où elle peut
laliberté guidés par le fax du haut de
leurs terrasses les dirigeants actuels
espère malgré tout que le gène ikke de
la technologie occidentale aidera les
chinois à prendre leur dernière bastien